Speaker 1: The latest so the latest one of
the latest scapegoats for the anti fact Republican
right wing has been electric vehicles.
Electric vehicles are seen as counter to big
boy patriotic oil burning Fords and Chevy's
and Dodge vehicles.
Electric vehicles are seen as sissy stuff.
In fact, I've actually told stories of so
often it will happen that when I show up at
a parking lot and park my electric vehicle
for two reasons.
One, I tend to park as far from wherever I'm
going as possible in the parking lot just
to walk as much as possible.
So even if there's a spot right up front,
I'll park at the back of the lot just to get
more more exercise, please, folks.
And also, just so my car doesn't get bashed
up, I'll usually park pretty far from other
vehicles and far from the stores.
Very often I will come out and find a domestic
pickup truck lifted with a vile exhaust parked
right next to my car.
Even though I'm near nobody and I know it's
an intimidation game, I know that the truck
drivers must know that.
I know that they have large genitals and it's
a penis size contest with these large trucks.
Okay, you get the gist of it.
The idea is the electric vehicles are not
manly and all of these different things, even
though they're way faster than all of these
gas powered vehicles.
But the new thing about it is the electric
vehicles are terrible for the country.
We don't have enough electricity for them.
And what about the batteries and what about
the oil companies?
And what about the car dealers?
Even though now every brand is selling vehicles
and they're selling them at their dealerships,
it's not just buy online Tesla vehicles.
So now Marjorie Taylor GREENE is escalating
her attack on electric vehicles and she's
doing so.
You may or may not be shocked to hear this
based on claims that are completely invalid.
Let's take a listen and then discuss New Deal.
Speaker 2: They want every single American
driving an electric vehicle and then they
have no plan in place for an energy structure
across America that can actually supply enough
electricity to charge all these electric vehicles.
Oh, this is going to fail.
It's not just going to fail.
It's going to cause blackouts.
It's going to cause deaths.
Speaker 1: People are going to die.
Speaker 2: It's going to cause Americans to
not be able to function like we always have.
It's it's going to send us back into the dark
ages.
That's what the Democrats are doing.
Speaker 1: Yep.
We're going to be back in the Dark Ages where
all you could have was volts burning gas.
Everything she's saying is untrue.
Everything she's saying is completely not
based, in fact, not based in reality whatsoever.
The truth is, the electrical system that's
putting people at risk of death is the Texas
electrical system that is by choice, isolated
from surrounding grids.
That is the.
Electrical system that risks people, people
dying.
So here's the way that they like to play this
up.
They say if everybody today switched over
to an electric vehicle, the grid wouldn't
be able to handle it.
And to some degree, that's true.
But nobody everybody can't switch over today
to electric vehicles.
Most electric vehicles have months, if not
years of wait times.
There's waiting lists.
Rivian has a multi-year waiting list.
Last I checked about six months ago.
And so there is actually a plan for the grid
to be able to support more electric vehicles.
And the idea is that over time, as more electric
vehicles are purchased, remember supply and
demand, the free market circumstances will
react to increased demand.
It will become more advantageous to put solar
panels on your roof the way that I have.
In order to fuel the grid.
Battery technology to store solar power is
going to come down.
And in terms of price, which it already is,
and we actually already know the answer and
I've talked about it before.
Over time, we want to move buildings to being
almost like self-contained power plants that
use the most efficient technology for heating
and cooling and for cooking, and also will
be able to charge the electric vehicles that
increasingly will be there now at all.
A lot of people are going to say, David, these
vehicles are expensive and induction ovens
are expensive and solar panels are expensive
and heat pump mini split systems are expensive.
It's all expensive.
But there is a plan in place which is over
time with incentives.
You get off of burning fossil fuels to power
all of this different stuff.
And the building you put solar panels on top
and then you switch over to efficient heat
pump heating and cooling systems and you get
off of gas for cooking and you've got low
energy consumption, induction cooktops with
convection ovens, and then you've got a vehicle
charger and the electric vehicle, and we're
in really good shape now.
I'm minimizing the scope of that change in
the United States.
But the point here is over time, as the demand
for the electric vehicles increases, all of
these other things are going to happen.
There's also a very interesting statistic,
which is if 80% of all passenger vehicles
became electric rate, four out of five, you
would only see a 10 to 15% increase in electricity
consumption.
So the the idea that it's as crazy as Marjorie
Taylor GREENE is making it out to be is also
wrong.
And then lastly, there's another really important
thing.
Electric vehicles on a per mile basis are
way more efficient than internal combustion
engines.
Engines.
So over time, if the move is from internal
combustion engines to electric vehicles, the
demand for electricity will go up.
Yes, but we have clean ways of generating
that electricity.
But the total energy used by passenger vehicles
will go down because the electric vehicles
are so much more efficient.
So this is all fearmongering.
It's fearmongering based on the false notion
that electric vehicles are some kind of sissy
woke, green agenda met or whatever.
It's just logical, if you would, if you care
about fast cars, electric vehicles are very,
very fast.
If you care about spending less on powering
the vehicles with expensive gasoline that
they talk about, the electric vehicles are
better.
It's better all around.
And the fact that they're now focused on it
and obsessed with it tells us a lot about
the real threat that electric vehicles put
on the status quo energy companies.
And that's a good thing.
It's actually a very good thing.